Такі потужні течії утворюються внаслідок припливів
та відпливів. Мало де у Шотландії течія така
сильна, як тут. До 40 кілометрів на годину.
Навіть риболовецький траулер не може
протистояти такій течії.
Джон МакАлістер - рибалка в кількох поколіннях.
Це він допоміг знайти найкраще місце
для розміщення припливної електростанції.
Течія йде крізь дуже вузький канал. Вона спершу
набирає сили, а потім спадає.
Із якою швидкістю?
Швидкість, можливо, до 20-22 вузлів,
наскільки я знаю. Маленькому човну
важко йти проти такої течії.
Рік тому Девід Стоддарт-Скотт та його
німецький колега знайшли в цій бухті
на заході Шотландії ідеальне місце, де розташувати
платформу. Течії, невидимі на поверхні, панують
на глибині. Вони рухають лопаті турбіни
припливної електростанції. Її рухливі генератори –
нове слово в техніці.
За допомогою цієї платформи ми можемо витягти
турбіну з води, з'ясувати, чи не пошкоджені лопаті,
чи необхідно почистити чи протестувати турбіни.
В разі потреби можемо замінити повністю
весь механізм.
На узбережжі розташований і офіс проекту.
Саме тут конструктори багато місяців
розробляли електростанцію.
Вона плаває на воді і водночас прикріплена
до дна сталевими тросами.
По кабелю струм постачається на берег
та забезпечує енергією 300 будинків.
Сталеву платформу будували шотландські партнери
А генератори та гвинти розробляла німецька фірма
Нільса Ланґе. Її профіль - виробництво двигунів
для човнів, зокрема на ось таких водних струменях.
Припливна енергія для компанії –
відносно нова сфера діяльності.
Це унікальний шанс для мене особисто,
для всієї команди. Не лише технічно розробити
новий продукт, а  й взяти участь у створенні
цілком нового ринку, як це було 25 років тому
з вітряною енергетикою.
Залишилось лише знайти інвесторів.
І ось перші з них біля замку ХХІ століття.
Вони вирушають до платформи.
Ідеться про мільйонні капіталовкладення.
Особливо вражений інвестор з Китаю.
А це - представник американського фонду,
який інвестує по всьому світу
в відновлювальну енергетику.
Ми зацікавились цією електростанцією, тому що
відновлювана енергія нині вкрай важлива.
Особливо в країнах, що розвиваються.
Електроенергія на викопному паливі -
не найкраще рішення. А ця енергія ідеально пасує
багатьом регіонам Африки, аби покрити
їхню потребу в струмі.
Платформа вже виробляє електроенергію.
Винахідники кажуть, цей струм дешевший,
ніж із дизельної електростанції.
Тож цей агрегат вже продано. До Філіппін.